at a memorial event for David Hamburg
Speaker Pelosi and I had a chance to
discuss impeachment mr. Dean who wrote
that I did haven't we've been too long
and not giving Trump a meaningful
moniker should it be deranged on
deadbeat Don demagogue Don thoughts
please comments mr. Dean who wrote that
I assume that was mine it was yours
we are witnessing Trump's massive
cover-up of his criminal behavior as
POTUS he's incapable of accomplishing
anything mr. Dean you know who wrote
that I suspect that was me again it was
you he should have said that was I but
that's just grammatical stuff um that
was today at the Judiciary Committee
hearing Jerry Nadler called lessons from
the Muller report presidential
obstruction and other crimes now
throughout this spectacle Dean revealed
himself as nothing more than a grossly
biased member of the anti-trump
resistance we all knew that but not only
that before the hearing even began he
appeared on his new home CNN it admitted
he wouldn't be establishing anything new
or even relevant I'm clearly not a fact
witness but I hope I can give them some
context and show them how strikingly
like Watergate what we're seeing now and
is reported in the Muller report is so
what the heck was the point of this
entire exercise on Capitol Hill well
here now the man you just saw exposed
John Dean Congressman Jim Jordan
remember the Judiciary Committee and
former Deputy Assistant Attorney General
John you all right congressman let's
start with you I'm glad you didn't do a
costume change for us still the same now
how could the Dems think that this was
going to advance any narrative this was
a PR son I'm surprised they didn't try
to you know levitate other people from
the Watergate era out of the grave but
what did they accomplish that I don't
know if they tompa's anything but this
is their pattern first first witness of
the 116th Congress their first big
announce witness was Michael Cohen guy
who went to prison for lying to Congress
they brought him in from Congress no
surprise he lied again we think seven
times then they bring in John Dean to
talk about obstruction of justice and of
course John Dean pled guilty to
obstruction of justice so this is just
their pattern and it's all about them
trying
to get the president that never forget
that the key chairman in the house have
these memorandums of understanding
actual contracts they've written among
themselves you're gonna do a I'm gonna
do B you're gonna do C I'm gonna do deed
this is how we're gonna have our
coordinated effort to get the president
so mo use Michael Cohen John Dean all
this is what they're gonna do and they
won't call it impeachment but that's
frankly what it is the American people
know it's wrong and John Dean was on CNN
tonight again trying to draw these
pathetic parallels to Watergate why is
he wrong if you wanted to have an expert
on how to commit obstruction of justice
and commit illegal campaign tricks well
they brought the expert in a guy who
pled guilty to it but there's nothing to
do with President Trump well also I
think I guess they're gonna call Bill
Clinton next when they start the
impeachment hearings is their first
witness but no there's another new
president Trump you know president Trump
compared to the Nixon administration
Watergate Trump made all those officials
available did not exercise executive
privilege against Special Counsel
made all the emails and documents
available so actually if you wanted to
draw a contrast between Watergate and
the Moller report you couldn't have done
better than actually bring John Dean to
testify yeah it kind of looks like mr.
Greenjeans from the Campton case he was
I think referencing you tonight he was
on CNN and others who are criticizing
his appearance congressman let's watch
were you taken aback at all by by how
personal some of the attacks by
Republicans were did you expect we're
going to be as contentious as well I did
actually I I know the players I've
watched them before I watched them
badger Hillary Clinton they're all flame
throwers I don't see the flame yeah no
and I didn't badger Hillary Clinton I
brought the facts the fact that you know
she wanted to blame the tragedy in
Benghazi on a video we all know that she
knew that was wrong when she when she
talked about that look here's the the
president was falsely accused of
conspiring with Russia to embarrass
curiosity about that fact why wouldn't
someone like John Dean especially be
concerned about exactly the point
falsely accused
but the
and then Bob Muller does a 22-month
investigation comes back and says no
collusion and there's no indictment on
the obstruction charge and yet the
Democrats want to say let's keep looking
at that versus looking at the false
accusation that started the whole thing
so to me that's the big problem here and
again John D here's the other connection
with Michael Cohen John Dean was giving
advice to lanny davis Michael Cohen's
lawyer the night before Oh
the night before Michael Cullen is
supposed to come testify John Dean's on
CNN paid contributor CNN and he tells
Erin Burnett on that show
I told lanny davis tell your client tell
michael cohen not to give his testimony
the republicans actually obstruct the
investigation of the Oversight Committee
that's what he told it so you talk about
mr. was right he is an expert on
obstruction he was actually advising
Michael Cohen to do that when he came
and testified four months ago Michael
Cohen follow his advice Michael Cohen
also lied it's become the resistance
media I mean this is seeing them I mean
James Earl Jones where does he go to get
his voiceover back John in a letter to
the House and Senate Judiciary
Committee's today the assistant attorney
general Stephen Boyd offered more
details on bars investigation into
surveillance against the Trump campaign
describing it as broad in scope and
multifaceted I was talking about Durham
the US attorney in Connecticut how
significant is that language John oh I
think that's tremendously significant
this is not going to be just one review
of a single FISA application let me also
point out congressman Jordan has done
great work and bringing to light a lot
of these shenanigans that were going on
at the very start of the investigation
but I'm not surprised Attorney General
Barr is going to conduct a broad
investigation because I hate to say it
more for my former colleagues in the
Justice Department the more we learn
about how this thing started the worse
and worse is going to get it isn't it is
it it is an obligation or duty of the
Attorney General to make sure that this
never happens in something like the
steel dossier could set us off on a
two-year mole hunt that tried to tear
down the Constitution amash Justin Amash
is stepping down from from well we had a
nice long meeting with Justin tonight
the board of the freedom caucus that
and mr. mas will be talking about that
we disagree with Justin's assessment of
this entire impeachment we strongly
disagree with him but Justin's a friend
mark of course is our Chairman and those
two will be talking about the situation
tomorrow do you have a lot of friends
who think like Justin Amash we don't but
but you know and he's wrong and we've
said he's he's sitting about to try to
destroy this presidency under false
pretences totally wrong
at totally disagree with his assessment
we made that clear they gonna run for
the nomination
I don't think so I don't think so I hope
not you know we want we want president
Trombley get rehired that's what we want
alright thanks so much John that both of
you